hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new iphone 12 pro max it's been a
long wait and today i'm going to be
comparing it to my
11 pro max and we're not only going to
talk about the typical things such as
cameras and performance
but i'm going to cover design and how
comfortable is such a large phone on top
of that we're going to talk about the
displays
we're going to talk about speakers 5g
and a lot more
let's go ahead and open it up and i have
to be honest with you guys
my heart is actually beating a little
bit it's been over a month and i've been
waiting and my biggest concern
is the size of this thing i've been
using the 12
pro i love the size i just don't know if
i'll be able to keep it and use it long
term to enjoy the cameras
now first impressions oh man
this reminds me of a demo of the when we
first opened up the 12
pros it feels so nice in the hand i like
it a lot more than i thought i would
okay can i compare it already let's feel
this
okay i am very happy i had to pause this
there for a second it doesn't feel
as bulky as i thought it would sure it
does feel heavy
you feel the flat sides it makes it feel
a little bit thicker even though it's
actually not
but man that is not bad i actually have
a little bit of a relief right now
let me set this down for just a second
and i want to briefly talk about
chargers i don't want to waste time
obviously we don't have the charging
brick anymore apple is not including
this with the phone
even though they do with the budget ipad
that's 300 bucks which is weird
but i would suggest not getting apples
but picking up one of these anchors
they're not a channel sponsor
yet but look how much smaller this is
they're both 20 watts
it's less expensive basically the size
of the five water
and if you're gonna be using magsafe it
actually charges faster than apples
do you want proof i actually have an
ultimate charger comparison
where i test out magsafe and i test out
a variety of chargers and show you guys
the speed differences check that video
out after you watch this one
as you guys could see magsafe it's not
new anymore people know about it
i gotta say even though the speeds
aren't fantastic which i cover there
it's still really enjoyable to use and
there's something very oddly satisfying
about this just a little click and if
the phone's on you get a little uh ping
oh there you go actually it turned it on
i've also been using the wallet now for
about a weekend
with the 12 pro and i gotta say that
i've actually really
enjoyed it it kind of fills in my hand
where i hold it
gives me a little bit more grip i've
never had it fall off
on accident so let's see how this works
with the 12 pro max
it's funny it looks kind of small on
here compared to the 12.
and it doesn't feel as nice because
there's an extra gap here that you feel
compared to the 12
but it does give you a little bit more
grip and some nice texture on the back
and now let's compare all of the
exterior differences i'm going to start
out by stacking them up
next to each other as you guys could
tell the 12 pro max is slightly taller
as far as the width it seems to be
identical i know the 12 for max is
slightly wider by a hair
comparing the sides you could see that
the power button
is much larger now and using the 12
pro over the last couple weeks i love
this new power button
it's nice and clicky it's a lot larger
reminds me of the
s10e with the fingerprint reader built
in
but no we don't have touch id there
you'll also notice that we have this
little plastic insert that is for 5g
which we'll talk about in just a bit
and the sim card slot has actually been
moved to
the other side and once again these
buttons are slightly larger and they're
more clicky
now before i compute all of the
differences in color i
have to say that i'm shocked by how
comfortable the 12 pro max is
in my hand now with the smaller phones
the 10s or the 11 pro this size with the
round edges your hands just kind of
wrap around it really well and then
going to the 12 pro
even though it is thinner technically
you just it just feels a lot more
substantial in your hand
but now i guess with when your phone is
this
large you just feel not as secure in the
hand
whereas with the new square edges on
this larger size it actually feels
better and i am so relieved about that
comparing the gold stainless steel frame
you could tell that the 12 pro max does
look more like
actual gold it's less orange maybe a
little bit more
yellow and it's brighter it pops a
little bit more which i do
like and along with that apple said that
this new gold has
the toughest coating out of any of the
different
iphone colors now if you look at the
back it's very
interesting the 12 pro max the gold
on the back it just looks almost like
white it's very interesting
um and then the 11 pro max it's more
gold looking and what's funny is last
year
i was wishing that this would be even
more gold looking than it was
but i guess with the lighter back it
does make the sides pop
a little bit more now you may have
noticed some differences in the camera
bumps
and the 12 pro axis is much bigger that
is because some of the lenses are larger
they are now
faster and of course we have the much
larger main
sensor with active sensor stabilization
which is awesome
and along with that the camera bumps do
stick out more so they're bigger
you'll also notice this black circle
which is the lidar sensor
here's a few examples for you guys over
the last few weeks with the 12 pro
the differences it makes in portrait
shots and then also
with video autofocus it has been awesome
now one other difference is the
microphone hole is tiny now
compared to before i was worried that
the audio quality would be worse but in
my testing it sounds
identical now if you haven't seen our
ultimate camera comparison with the 12
pro against the 11 pro
and even the 10s go and check that out
after this video there's a lot of
interesting differences
but we'll be comparing these two at the
end first let's go and flip these over
and compare the displays
we now have that larger 6.7 inch screen
you guys could see the differences it's
definitely noticeable with the larger
screen size
as you can see the bezels are more slim
on the 12
pro and that is because it's now
completely
flat so we actually just have glass that
meets this frame compared to having
a little plastic insert and because of
that you actually get a nice
little uh edge of gold color whereas
with the 11 pro it kind of blends
in with the sides and the bezel now the
notch might look smaller on the new 12
pro but it's actually identical in size
it just looks smaller because we have
extra space on the sides and
up top here because the bezels are
thinner now
as far as face id nothing has changed
the sensors are identical the speeds are
identical
so no difference there and now let's
compare the displays
some people say that these have
identical displays
and that's not true there's actually a
surprising amount of differences now
they are both
60 hertz so unfortunately we don't have
120 hertz in an iphone and that's
probably because of battery life
we'll talk about that in just a bit now
obviously the screen is
larger so it's not the same panel but
one thing you guys may notice
is that the new 12 pro has a warmer
white balance the screen is warmer
compared to the 11 pro being cooler and
apple's heading that way
with all of their devices now i do have
true tone turned on on both of them but
even if i turn that
off you guys could still see the
difference here
and the other difference is the color
shift if you're viewing the phone off
axis
as you guys could see the 11 pro and
older oled screens they all turn blue
when you look from the side
but the 12s are the first ones where
they stay nice and consistent
and as far as brightness i have both in
manual and set to max
and they look identical so no
differences there
and as far as watching hdr videos i also
see
no difference in hdr but both of them
look excellent you have a great hdr
viewing experience
the only difference is the 12 pro max
does have a warmer color balance
and now let's compare the speakers apple
didn't mention that there are any
differences
i already know that there are with the
regular 12 pro but let's put these head
to head
you make sure to put on a pair of
headphones and let's take a listen
[Music]
get me
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below i'll let you guys
know
what i heard so there are a couple
differences the speakers have definitely
been
improved even though apple didn't tell
us anything it's most
clear in the highs because they're very
clear they're very sharp
um the mids and the base it's a little
bit more rich but it's not as
significant of a difference
now my previous test i actually measured
a two decibel
difference with my apple watch so it's
definitely louder
and just judging on my past experience
with the 12 pro
the highs are just really crisp and with
some voices and some music
it might be a little bit too much
depending on your ears but in general
it's a nice improvement and now let's
get into performance we're going to
start out by testing the data speeds i'm
going to pop my sim into the new 12
pro we're going to open up our speed
test app and as you guys can see just
like before
the 12 pro with 5g is showing one bar
less of connectivity
than the 11 pro where connect the same
server i'm gonna go ahead and hit
run and as you guys can see the data
speeds
are massive this is actually very
similar to our 11 versus 12 pro
comparison now once again we have snow
outside um we're in spokane
we're in a concrete building and that is
some nice
speed differences now some people said
you don't want to run them at the same
time
honestly i've had a consistent result
either way there's you know
thousands of people connecting to the
same tower pulling data at the same time
and i do want to point out that i have a
crazy in-depth
lte comparison both with 5g and just
standard lte of the 12 pro
against the 11 pro i went around the
whole city i even tested
tethering speeds and there were some
massive differences you guys could check
out that video
if you want to know more about lte but
overall
the 12 pro it is much better even with
lte because it's using a snapdragon x55
modem which is the best that's currently
on the market compared to an
intel modem with the 11 pro max and as
you guys know
intel is falling a little bit behind now
in a lot of different ways
and now let's compare the cpu and the
graphics performance i have geekbench 5
opened up right here
we have apple's a13 bionic which was
already faster than all the android
processors
now with the 12 pro max we have the a14
bionic it actually just says arm here
it's not updated i'm gonna go ahead and
run the cpu test
but one thing i want to point out is the
difference in ram we have six gigs
compared to four gigs now four gigs was
not
enough for somebody that is a heavy user
power user
i kept having apps they would close in
the background apps that i would use a
couple hours ago and sometimes even apps
that i was just using if i'd go into the
camera app
and i would take a photo or a few of
them thankfully with the 12 pro
the last few weeks it has been excellent
with that six gigs of ram
apps are staying open i don't have that
issue anymore our scores are in and i
think
this is the highest multi-core i've seen
on an iphone 12
yet as far as single core we're looking
at 1331 compared to 1603
1331 already beats out most macbooks my
mac pro
1603 is awesome so here we have close to
25
improvement and as far as multi-core
we're going from 35-33
up to 42-84 the highest core i have seen
very great performance and that's over
20 improvement now
one thing that we're not seeing here is
the fact that the neural engine now has
twice as many cores
and those are more powerful as well so
apple is really focused
on machine learning not just regular cpu
performance
now i'm also going to test out video
editing in just a bit but first let's
run
our metal test for the graphics
and here are the results and to be
honest i was expecting
a little bit more we have 74 47 compared
to 92.74
that's close to 25 improvement so that
is still
a good improvement there but what's very
interesting
is that if i go back to my history with
the older version ios 13
we were looking at 6400 6100
and then switching over to ios 14 we
have a massive
gain in performance just because of
optimization
so there's a chance we could get better
performance in the future with the
iphone 12 pro max now one thing i know
is that
the 12 pros they are even the regular 12
they're using more power for
graphics now they're getting better
performance but using more power so
vadim is going to be doing a gaming
comparison
uh with the 11 pro max against the 12
pro max and also looking at
battery life when you're gaming that
could be very important so if you guys
want to see that
make sure you guys subscribe below and
we're trying to hit 500k subscribers
before the end of the year so if you
guys want to help us out
we would definitely appreciate it and
now let's compare video editing i have a
project here that's a little bit over a
minute long
and some of these clips are dolby vision
hdr clips
as you guys can see it's actually
playing back in hdr it might be blowing
out the camera up there
now both are playing it back perfectly
smoothly and even though the iphone 11
pro can't shoot dolby vision
it could still display on that oled
screen whereas the 12 pro max it could
shoot
hdr up to 4k 60fps
which is awesome and you can take
advantage of the display so the a13 is
not having any issues here let's go
ahead and scroll
and see if we notice any difference in
smoothness
and it's really hard to tell you guys
let me know if you guys could tell
any difference now i'm going to go ahead
oh i saw a couple of draw frames there
i'm going to go ahead and add a theme to
this blockbuster
perfect maybe we'll add a soundtrack to
it
there you go and then we're gonna go and
export this and it
actually got started we can already tell
that the a14
is definitely speeding along here
it's almost done now whereas the a13 is
about halfway
so it looks like it took 46 seconds
for a one minute and 13 second project
and some of this footage is
4k 60 with hdr both of them are
done and there's the final video and as
you see it's actually saved in dolby
vision hdr playing back
which is awesome so our iphone 12 for
max took 47 seconds
11 pro max took 67 seconds so that's a
45
improvement in speed much higher than
the 20 to 25
improvements that we saw in just raw cpu
power and now let's talk about the
battery life the max
models always have the best they have
the largest batteries but
this year we actually lost almost 300
milliamp hours of battery going from
almost 4000
to 36.87 that's because the phone is
thinner they had to put a smaller
battery in there now
as far as battery life i'm gonna be
testing both these and comparing them
in my one week of real world comparison
and seeing
if the 12 pro max keeps up with how
great the 11 pro max was now from what
i've seen
so far in terms of battery mr who's the
boss did his
test and there there's only a half hour
difference between the two
and one thing to keep in mind is that he
runs a bunch of games and even
benchmarks
that really draw a lot of power from the
new graphic so it's gonna be very
interesting to see
what kind of difference we get in the
real world and now let's get into
the camera comparison now right now i'm
recording video this is 4k using the
front-facing cameras
and you guys let me know do you guys
notice a difference in terms of video
quality
and also how about the microphone
quality let me know down in the comments
section
which one looks and which one sounds
better now the front sensors
are exactly the same but we have a
software difference now
because the 12 pro max has better
diffusion and smart hdr3
you guys let me know which one of these
front-facing photos
looks better to you the same thing goes
for the
ultra wides they're identical cameras
but because of defusion we had some nice
improvements
in my previous tests another improvement
is distortion take a look at those
ceiling tiles
the 11 pro max hasn't warped same thing
with the table
whereas at 12 pro max all the lines are
really straight
the ultra ride along with the front
facing camera can now shoot
night mode shots you guys can see the
differences here they are massive
so this has been a great improvement and
thanks to lidar you can shoot
night mode portrait shots as well here's
one comparing the pro maxes
and this can make a small improvement or
if it's really dark here's a shot
comparing
my 12 pro and this is a huge difference
here
and another difference is that for the
first time ever
our telephoto lens is actually 2.5 times
zoom and that's something that is
exclusive to the 12 pro max so you guys
can see
that i'm closer here here's the
difference if you're taking a portrait
shot of a person you guys can see how
much closer it is
and then here's another photo if you're
matching both of them up
and you guys can comment below telling
me which one looks better in terms of
image quality
now here's another shot for you guys to
compare the deep fusion and the low
light performance
can you tell any difference whatsoever
it's interesting that the 12 pro max has
a f 2.2
aperture now instead of an f2 for that
telephoto lens
so that could hurt the low light
performance a bit but then again with
the newer software that could make up
for it
and here's a portrait shot of my
blackmagic pocket 4k
and there's some definite differences
other than just being more
zoomed in which i actually accounted for
look at the bokeh up top the bokeh
is really much more substantial and in
general there's a lot more blur that is
being added
let me go into the edit mode and see if
there's a default
no look it actually defaults to the same
f 4.5 i thought maybe
it would be a little different but i
guess just like with the real camera
if you have a longer telephoto lens you
will get more blur so apple actually
accounted for that that is very
interesting now there's another
difference i see here
look right here between uh the little
ssd mount
the iphone 11 pro wasn't able to
actually cut that out
but the 12 pro max it got all the
cutouts
perfectly and i'm guessing that's
because of the lidar
sensor actually knowing a lot more depth
information
now to be honest this is actually too
much blur on the 12 pro max i mean it's
acting like a real lens because i was
close
to this camera but the beauty of an
iphone is after the shot is taken
you can just go in here and turn this
down
make the shot exactly how you want there
you go whereas
with a regular camera you can't do that
and now let's talk about the prices and
our final
verdict the 12 pro max cost the same
1099 dollars as the 11 pro max did
so prices are the same but we do get
double the storage 128 gigs
compared to 64. and i would say in 2020
even 2019
128 gig is really the minimum that you
want with the 11 pro max you had to
spend another 150 bucks
and you were forced to buy 256 gig
of course we do have two extra gigs of
ram which is nice
that definitely helps now i have to
mention that we did lose that power
brick which apple is now selling for 19
but the cost to build the 12 for max is
a lot higher than the 11 pro max we have
the extra
modem from snapdragon the best one so
that is a costly
part and then with that we have the
newer cameras and we have
image stabilization in the main sensor
which costs more money as well
so overall you are definitely getting a
much better deal
now the other question is should you
upgrade from the 11 pro max to the 12
pro max
i would say absolutely for me just the
speed differences
in the lte and 5g is huge if you guys
didn't see my 5g video
there's a lot of reasons there for
tethering that's been a massive
improvement but overall
this is an awesome flagship phone that
hits almost all the boxes
other than 120 hertz that's probably
gonna be for next year let me know your
thoughts down in the comments section is
it worth
upgrading and if you guys want to see my
real world one week
comparison click that circle above and
then you guys can help us
try to reach 500k before the end of the
year if you guys want to see
that 5g comparison or maybe our magsafe
charger comparison we have a couple
videos
right over there thank you guys for
watching this been max and i will see
you in the next video